I want to tell you what the biggest
point of stress is in my life this is
your the biggest point of stress in my
life is using bathrooms that aren't mine
I couldn't be more serious right now
it's not relationships it's not my house
it's not it's being anywhere other than
my own house when the quesadillas start
doing what they do I don't want to be
there I want to be at home when you're
someone else's house you never know what
you're gonna deal with what kind of
bathroom they have it's literally a
crapshoot
thank you hey we got a great show
jinke Salinger's it's the crapshoot
monologue what I'm saying is there's two
types of bathrooms that I'm aware of in
the homes welcoming bathrooms and
unwelcoming bathrooms me you come to my
place don't worry welcoming I got that I
got that good baby six rolls of
toilet paper in plain sight back up
right there I level it's not under the
sink under the sink I love like a spice
rack it's right there plungers not hidin
either he's readily available crowd he's
practically saluting good do your worst
but then there's the unwelcoming
bathroom and this is the kind I had
growing up in my house it's cold lonely
minimalist it's like a German art
installation and I'm in the cold steel
of the sink reminds me that we're all
alone no magazines of course no
magazines decorative soaps still in the
wrapping that's an unwelcoming bathroom
right there when they're still wrapped
you're like can I
crinkling can I use this and they're
just like what on earth would you be
doing in there that would require hand
watching what I don't know what you
think goes on in there that's our mirror
room and it doesn't even have to be a
fancy bathroom to be an unwelcoming
bathroom sometimes you just go on a
regular run-of-the-mill bathroom but
it's still unwelcoming because they only
have one towel and it's the towel they
use to dry off after the shower
so now you've washed your hands and
instead of just drying them you're
playing a fun game of which part of this
towel didn't touch my uncle's balls I've
literally been there like do you do the
corners the corners safe the corners
either the worst because you're like
yeah I can't quite Corner two monologues
now that I've done this but it doesn't
get any worse than public restrooms we
all know this especially the men's room
urinals not a fan don't like urinals
what is this Mad Max it's it's it's
what's that word on that last card it's
savage worth worth it
we're a transparent show array we have
good timer we're on a rhythm but I
didn't see savage it doesn't and here we
are deal with this have the time the
dividers are too low there's no divider
so you're standing next to some stranger
just fully explode
[Applause]
we've been canceled what I'm saying is
you're those are the words the big
punchline is why don't we just stand in
the tub naked like five-year-olds having
a sword fight is that that's where we
were going we can just jump right there
it doesn't matter
and there's the stalls yep monologues
still going
why does the public restroom stall
always got to be three feet above the
ground that door three feet above the
ground who built these things don't they
now what's happening in there I'm going
the bathroom it's not a voting booth
there's always that gap like a generous
gap like the cost of doors we got a
smaller doors smaller door going
bankrupt give me a tiny door I wanted to
be like a saloon
that's why don't with stahls if I'm
gonna go on public you got to give me a
one-seater level one seater it's a
studio apartment of public restrooms but
really for me a good one seater it's all
about the lock what kind of lock we
working with better be that deadbolt I
love the feeling of a deadbolt you're
like I'm in God's hands that push-button
handle
that's for the birds beat it push button
handle you lock and handle should be
separate handles too flimsy to trust
with the lock he's like I got it
jiggling you don't got
I don't just you you push it in there's
no way to test if it's locked
without unlocking it that's a good
feeling right before you turn and take
three gigantic steps turn around to a
pantless 180 and just stare back at that
door you don't trust any second map pop
buttons gonna push out like a turkey
timer so you can be at your worst it's
like this might surprise you but my
favorite public bathroom is actually on
the airplane they're the absolute best
they offer ultimate privacy airplane
bathroom you kind of feel like the pilot
you know I mean you got your own door
you got buttons and knobs you can turn
and push and you're both trying to land
something thank you thank you so much
[Applause]
really nice for me
best part hands down on the airplane
toilet is the flesh
I love the flush it's so dramatic
there's always that pause you know I
mean they make you wait for it you're
like oh no what do
and you're like oh it's a button and you
push it anyway it's so good it just
sucks it out it's so definitive it
shouldn't even be called a flush that's
what a normal toilet does an airplane
toilet through massive suction
completely gets rid of whatever you did
like Tony Soprano style no evidence no
trace no sign it ever existed just like
don't work we took care of it
[Applause]
[Music]